the dead in canada who got arrested for
not using the proper pronouns for his
child child yeah that's the safe way to
say
well no because i don't know i don't
know what the uh the actual gender of
the child is because
depending on which source you read
they'll say something different so
you know you you'll read the new york
times and it'll say the man's daughter
and then you'll read say the daily wire
i'll say the man's son yeah and so i'm
sorry
but you see that this is trust you know
what i mean that issue to me is why it
all
is so important the thing that drives me
craziest are these conservatives who
they're
they're in that ladder group of people
with pc where they say oh come on you
know
i'll you do you i'm not gonna it doesn't
affect me do whatever you want just
don't raise my taxes or whatever
it does if there are very few people who
are men who think that they're women or
vice versa very very few people it's a
social contagion also beyond the
psychological issue so
it is growing especially among younger
people but taking that aside it's still
a small number of people
if if i can't
know if i can't make a claim about
objective reality that you will respect
and you can't make a claim about
objective reality that i will respect
in something as fundamental as the most
basic distinction in human nature
who's a boy and who's a girl then we
can't communicate
right what is language it's just it's
symbols that we use to
refer to objective reality and try to
shape the kind of world that we want to
live in
and recognize reality if we if yeah
if we cannot do that there is no
self-government there is no logic to
this place it's just
warring bands of interests the
interesting thing about when it comes to
and this is a really obviously dangerous
subject for youtube especially yeah you
know it's like
walking on ice because they're ready to
just hit the nuke button yeah but i was
reading something about
um i can't remember what it was it was a
year or so ago about
a world world-class athlete who had won
some competitions the individual used he
him pronouns but was
biologically female it completely
altered the context
of everything because
in in certain sporting events i can tell
you who the world-class top athletes are
yeah there's probably the names of
there's probably several names in say
the wnba you've probably never heard of
probably more than several right well
then
i don't know if it was you tweeted that
joke and i tweeted the uh the family guy
clip
maybe it wasn't you wasn't you i did see
the clown i don't i forget if i tweeted
it or not yeah yeah
anyway if you have we'll use the wnba
as an example lebron james particularly
woke in many ways
yeah and pro ccp and we all know he's
like the cream of the crop the best of
the best
they say he commands you know hundreds
of millions of dollars a year
let's say you have uh and again i'm
saying this with the utmost respect i'm
trying to explain a concept of
linguistics and understanding of reality
let's say you have a wnba player
who is called the top of her league the
best of the best
commanding the highest salary in the
league and then the person comes out as
trans
so in the encyclopedia sacrapedia they
change all the pronouns
from she to he and him yeah now it says
he commands the highest salary in the
league
he won all of the greatest championships
and it really changes the context
because now it sounds like
they're actually above lebron james
right so i need to be able to understand
the context
and these things matter well it matters
to the very essence of the society i
mean
you know you you love philosophy and so
this
there's this very shallow idea that you
know you keep your religion out of my
politics you
look man that's to quote the dude that
man that's just your opinion man you
know so don't
just let we're just going to talk about
taxes or whatever no all
all laws legislate morality all human
conflict ultimately is theological
you know there's the breitbart doctrine
which is politics is downstream of
culture culture is downstream of
religion cult and culture they come from
the same root word ultimately we're
talking about
first principles who we are the
traditional understanding for our whole
civilization
everywhere everywhere in the world
certainly in this country
is that we are you know body and soul
and yes i'll i'll move i'll bring you
back to one more route and that's
religion is it comes after moral
frameworks yeah well yeah exactly
this is actually a perfect way to put it
as moral frameworks
if if i'm going to explain human nature
to in the old way
i'm body and soul right and for the
purposes of a lot of public policy i
might just be body but but not for all
public policy you know why is
why is sexual assault worse than any
other kind of assault
because we're more than just our bodies
right there's there's a kind of human
dignity that's being violated here okay
fine
that's the the to use the technical term
the hylomorphic view
of human nature there's the materialist
view which is just for meat puppets
and then there's the transgender view
which is an ancient heresy it's called
gnostic dualism
it's the idea that my true self has
nothing to do with my body so i might
look like a dude i got a deep voice i
got the adam's apple
various other appendages but if on some
deep
metaphysical level i feel myself to be a
woman
not only is it sort of complicated you
know and i'm a little bit i'm i'm just a
woman
because my myself my actual self has
nothing to do with my body
you can't live in a society that
simultaneously holds these
contradict reviews of what human nature
is you've got to decide
i you have you seen the the jack dorsey
thing i did with joe rogan
yeah it was just absolutely magnificent
i appreciate it yes uh it comes up a lot
but i think there was like a very
important point that uh i brought up to
jack or to vijaya
and it's that when i said your rules are
inherently biased against conservatives
they didn't understand this yeah and
then i said conservatives view the
phrase misgendering differently from the
way you
view it right and you can argue that
you're in the majority they can argue
they're the majority
how do you rectify that bias you have if
half the country votes for donald trump
and the other half doesn't you can it's
fair to say that half the voting body
that are active in politics
believe that misgendering someone means
to use pronouns that don't align with
their biological
sex yeah the so that's the essentialist
view then the constructivist view would
be
the other way around that misgendering
is when you don't use the pronouns that
adhere to their
self-identification yeah we right now
have an infrastructure that's being
built upon
you as a conservative your world view is
considered wrong a moral or
or a fringe even though i think when you
look at the data it's actually the
majority of individuals would
certainly which i go back to the
politically uninitiated versus initiated
yeah
my thing comes down to probably like
more libertarianism
in the small l sense not the libertarian
party because you know kind of kooky
in that if someone comes to me and says
here's what i'd like to be called i say
no problemo yeah absolutely and
i don't think that twitter's argument
for why
they ban people who violence policy is
sufficient
i don't think youtube's is and i think
it's causing serious damage as you
probably agree to
discourse and politics there the
argument was that there's a high rate of
suicide among trans people therefore
yeah
and my argument uh it's not even i'm
arguing against
the right of individuals to be respected
you know i i don't think everyone has a
right to just have respect yeah i do
think society
my personal opinion is we try to give
people the benefit of the doubt towards
respecting them
until they prove otherwise but it does
raise this question which is
and and this is actually just as
dangerous for society what is the
respect it seems to me
what the conservatives are saying is if
i see a man who wants to be called a
woman
and you call him a man you're showing
him respect because you are you're not
treating him like a crazy person you're
treating him like someone
who can understand reality and you're
just saying look this is
this is how i see it pal it kind of
looks like you're a man and if you lie
to him
then you're being very disrespectful you
don't lie to people that you have
respect for
but i think on the left the argument
they're making is lies in this case
even if we're all we're going to all
admit you know he's not really a girl
but
it's nice because it's socially
constructed we should all do it
lies are compassionate and the truth is
cruel
and you know that's not a great premise
for a society
to begin with and it's one that i would
certainly reject it i think i think at
the very least it's exactly
you know everything you online outlined
the conservative view on why
you're actually being respectful it's
exactly the problem with the rules these
social media companies have
yeah in that they you know what i said
what i said to them was
you guys think you're like regular
people but you're not you're
billionaire silicon valley elites who
are out of touch with this country
masters of the universe
i'm not saying you're that you represent
a tiny fringe faction
or anything like that there's a lot of
people who agree with you yeah but you
don't understand
that you have not spoken with a trump
supporter or conservative
to understand that half the country
disagrees with you and
probably more but you've made rules so
what ends up happening is
the more we use these digital spaces the
more we're filtering our world view
through theirs
yeah and it's your point about losing
that's probably it
it is because we're i think
what twitter is saying i mean you you
absolutely wrecked them and and they're
being so hypocritical and they're being
so disingenuous a lot of the time
but the fact remains there are going to
be rules
always have been always will be to every
speech regime
there have to be there just have to be
rules to speech in the sense that
if he is really he then he isn't she and
if he is
is she then he's really not he and one
of us is right and one of us is wrong
but we will ha if we're going to have
any kind of society we're going to have
to agree on those rules
and what is being done now is rather
than having them
develop over time out of tradition
through the use of our reason
by applying reason to the natural world
and our perceptions
what is being done is a handful of
extremely radical
people whose whose life experience is
very different from all of ours
are upending society right from out from
under our feet
and there's nothing we can do about it
because they own the platforms and they
enforce all the rules and you got like
jack dorsey who sold twitter
basically he only owns like two or six
percent or something of twitter now and
you've got companies like state street
or um blackrock these giant investment
global investment firms that basically
are running the show
and like you said earlier sedition like
type certain types of speech are illegal
for a reason and there is so free speech
means we're not we've all agreed we're
not going to say certain things
and it's like they've taken on this role
of arbiter that they want to
decide for us that we can't say certain
things because
it's dangerous that it will prevent
actual free speech
but i don't think that that's for
corporations to decide personally
not not historically in our country but
that is what's happening now and it's
it's why i think the reason
conservatives lose is because the left
makes a procedural argument
and they make a substantive argument and
what i mean by that is
the left has a view of what free speech
is in the abstract and then they're
going to enforce
certain speech rules the right
has this kind of a historical now we've
adopted over the last 20 years just like
total free speech and there's no limits
to anything
but we won't say what we should say but
free speech has no meaning to people
who have nothing to say freedom of
belief has no meaning to people who
don't believe anything
you know you know what the reason i
think it's not just conservatives who
are losing because
obviously to you i'm definitely a
conservative to the right i'm definitely
not a conservative to them
whatever fine but uh we are losing
and whatever that we is it's a
combination of different factions
in politics but the reason is well i i
don't think you're interested in
lying cheating and stealing right uh i'm
certainly not either yeah
i like enlightenment values i like
sitting down having conversations with
people i believe in
respecting uh so for me when it comes to
you know pronouns or whatever i give the
benefit of doubt towards respect
i like to sit down and have
conversations i don't like to manipulate
people into doing my bidding
yeah however the issue i have with
modern leftism as it stands
is is the authoritarianism of it where
they believe
their the moral framework of of wokeness
is
might makes right yeah are you familiar
with david graber
no i'm not david graber was a very
famous anthropologist
who uh didn't like that he was called
the anarchist anthropologist he was one
of the
most he was one of the influencers who
ignited occupy wall street at these
meetings
and uh he passed recently so you know
rest in peace david graber
he did a twitter thread a few years ago
where he said elements of the left have
begun adopting fascistic ideologies
the idea that there's no truth but power
and that mike might makes right
yeah that's my problem with wokeness
yeah that they're basically
there's no rules i want to know what the
rules are so i can respect you
yeah but they purposefully have no rules
it's just the imposition is what matters
you know
at this point is so important someone
the other day well this happens every
day but the other day i responded
someone called me a fascist
and i pointed out i said i am way too
reactionary to be a fascist
and that is like small potatoes and what
i mean by that is
to your point exactly fascism is
an atheistic status philosophy that
basically just worships
the the exercise of state power that
doesn't work with my world view because
i think that there are some things that
are
true i think there are eternal truths
there's an eternal moral order
but this is something that conservatives
don't want to acknowledge when i say
they don't want to say anything what i
mean is this
you get the squishy types who say well
look you know if we tell
drag queen story hour that they can't
twerk for kids at the library
then they might tell us we can't go to
church on sunday and they say like first
of all they're already telling us we
can't go to church on sunday
but but second of all if you cannot
distinguish
between twerking for toddlers and going
to church on sunday
if you can't say one of those is better
than the other one
one of those is better for then you have
lost your faculties of judgment your
moral conscience
which is the prerequisite for
self-government at that point throw in
the towel well
i'll i'll i'll put it in a different way
let's say you have
let's say i'm sitting in my my arbiter's
chair and i see a leftist say
we should be allowed to have you know
drag queen story hour
and then to my right is a conservative
saying we should be able to go to church
on sunday
i say to the to you and your community
on the religious side you should be
allowed to go to church and your
community should function
as you you see moral and fit and this
other group they live in a different
society
if you guys want to have and live your
own ways i respect that the problem
though
is one group is telling you what you can
and can't do because they're trying to
impose their will
into your community but in their defense
i am trying to impose my will on theirs
and what i mean by what i mean by that
is this
drag queen story hour involves perverts
twerking for toddlers
okay to put it really bluntly well to
clarify too
there's a specific instance in which
somebody was that's what i'm yeah i'm
not speaking loosely here i'm saying
like an actual a guy who actually
committed these crimes right
because this is so much easier to get
into it this way because it involves
children
if a community you know look they've got
their own customs and one of the customs
is
that they abuse children and they twerk
for children and they indoctrinate
children into this crazy
licentious ideology but that's their
custom that's what they want to do
do we not have any right to say uh you
shouldn't do that
depends on if you're coming from uh
it's hard it's it's moral frameworks
it's i certainly have my red lines
you know so i look at what happens in
some of these foreign countries
and they're shocking to me and there's a
point where i'm like questioning the
line of warfare for instance what china
does to
the uighur muslims and the women and i
had a very interesting conversation with
cassandra fairbanks where she said
there's no there's no war no matter what
like every country does something wrong
are we gonna go to war with everybody
yeah
it's a very interesting libertarian
argument and i think i think she's right
about that
why why don't i care about say these
other countries in you know in africa
where they do
their atrocities as well and so it's
it's a real challenge of
where the lines are in in in terms of
like the actual physical boundaries
where we're going to say we will enforce
our morality
well i'm sure i'm sure a line for you
would be like the kid stuff i think this
is true a line for most people
because what do we also we say kids
can't consent you know they don't they
don't
really have mastery of their liberty
that's why we have age of consent laws
because we're not going to let
kids do all these sorts of things the
left is trying to uh catch away at that
right now and i'll clarify too right
there's there's the mainstream media
portrayal of drag queen story hour where
it's just people in chairs with books
yeah and there's the actual videos you
see on twitter where they're twerking
for children
yes and so there's the the argument
that i've seen is that twerking is just
dancing from a different culture
so you you you just like a waltz you
know from a philosophical point of view
and and from a moral from a moral
framework standpoint
my question is are people who vote for
certain things allowed to live certain
ways
if they choose and at what point does
someone's community get to impose their
will in another community
well it depends what they're voting for
you know at one time i got to meet
scalia a couple times
and when i was a student it was amazing
i have no idea how i stumbled into this
opportunity
and someone asked him it was a question
about the second amendment they asked
him hold on
mr justice because you're saying that
it's this individual right to these guns
but only these guns not these other guns
how do you decide and his answer i
thought was deeply conservative and
deeply wise
he said you decide very very carefully
and i think we need to decide these
things very carefully too
one stumbling block i think for a lot of
people on this issue
is the nature of liberty what is liberty
you know if
right now they're saying that the kid
should be able to be castrated if he if
he wants to
because that it's his right that's his
liberty if he wants to do it but
but then we say well kids don't really
have liberty because they're not
educated and the whole point of that
liberal education is
you master your liberty i think the
problem here is this conflation of
liberty and licentiousness meaning
the current sort of modern lib view of
liberty is that liberty means do
whatever you want whatever your base
desire is just do whatever you want
and the the conservative view of liberty
the view of the founders the view of the
christian view the pre-christian view
even
is that liberty is not the ability to do
whatever you want it's the
right to do what you ought to do and
what i mean by that is this i can bring
it right down to earth
a heroin addict actually is a very
popular debate on libertarian circles
right
should you legalize all the drugs should
the heroin addict be able to do whatever
he wants
according to the modern liberal view of
liberty the heroin addict is the most
free guy in the world right he can do as
long as he's got a buck in his pocket he
can shoot up he's that's awesome he's
pursuing his will and his free choice
but we all know that that guy's not free
we all know he's a slave
he's a slave to his base passions his
higher will i'm sure is telling him
i wish i could stop doing this i hate
the heroine oh addicts will tell you
this all the time
but his lower appetites because he
hasn't cultivated his higher will his
lower appetites his licentiousness
desiring all of that my my view of the
drug war stuff is it should be legal
in so far as you have to go to
designated facilities that regulate
and actually wean you off of it so
instead of having someone go in the
gutter
they go in for a legal you know session
or whatever
and they can lim they can regulate and
limit so that they can actually
with the purpose of getting them off the
drug right right yeah that makes you
know we have methadone clinics and
things like that yeah
so but but there are people who look at
say portugal and they think we should
just totally legalize everything
yeah i am of i am of the legalize
everything with regulation
so it's like or i should say
decriminalize with the goal of
helping people instead of you know
locking them up in prison or whatever
but but even in that view that isn't
that isn't exactly my view of it but
even in that view
you are acknowledging the goal should be
people do less of this stuff absolutely
yeah and i think a lot of people now on
the left
they say it's it's kind of like the
abortion thing right it's like no we got
to celebrate it we got to shout it and
that's and that's that
way lies madness you know it to me that
whole thing was crazy because
you know growing up being uh liberal it
it what meant to me and what my
understanding of the things we argued
for was
respecting individual liberties and
civil liberties and civil rights
now the modern liberal whatever that
means does not do that
yeah it's it's well i mean they can
argue that they are
but it's moved well beyond any point of
being responsible in your community
to protect individuals now it's
literally just
no rules no police but you know where
you want to burn down the city in
minneapolis or whatever i can't i've got
to defend the left i mean your point is
totally right
but their argument which they really
pushed in the 1970s the radical
feminists pushed this
is that the personal is the political
there's this great
essay it's by that name and this woman
recounts how the new york radical
women's groups
they would meet up i refer to them as
wine and cheese soirees you know these
sort of housewives or
unmarried women would meet up and but
very often when the
bourgeois housewife and the mother of
two would show up the woman would go
there and she was happy as a clam
walking in
and then during the struggle session
they would raise awareness and the woman
would leave
resentful and irritated and because
she's now aware of her own
oppression and this is called being
liberated and then the women would go
out of there
you know uh i used to do non-profit
fundraising and
these these offices they hire large
groups of people send us out in the
streets to wave at people with
clipboards yeah hey do you have a minute
to talk about the environment you've
probably seen those people right
one when you come back from your day of
hard fundraising on the street
yeah some people aren't of strong mental
fortitude
and they would do debriefs they would
always have a manager do a debrief with
every one one at a time and then you
you stop before debrief then you'd leave
and what they were really doing was
a morality check if somebody in the
office had a bad day
they would walk in and they would have
the squiggly line over their head like
the comics
and everyone else who maybe had a bad
day but wasn't really thinking about it
maybe it was an okay day it was a good
day
yeah they'd all be hanging out after
work the person had a bad day
would stand next to them as they say
like how was your day and they'd be like
it was okay for me and they'll go this
is the worst job ever i hate this job
dude people are so awful
dude i had a guy he did this to me and
then everyone starts sharing the
negativity and it spreads
like like a virus yeah so what would
happen is they would do a debrief where
they would ask people how was your day
how do you feel and if
a tiny percentage of people were like
i'm just so tired these people are so
awful
they'd fire everyone in the office
even there was like there would be like
five people who would remain and those
were like the tough willed
so i worked for these companies i was a
nation's best fundraiser for a variety
of these
nonprofits on the street convincing
people to donate to various charities i
didn't think
those guys ever got anybody to sign up
at all that's very impressive
i i i once got a lady to give me a check
for 700
and then give me her bank account
numbers to do it every single month
so like when you have the gift of gab
when you can talk
i'm in the wrong line of work man that's
great no i think you're in the right
line of work
like this this stuff was dirty it was
it's the opposite of what we're doing
you're speaking
your your truth you're explaining how
you feel and how you want to you know
your goals towards improving things this
was the opposite this was
tricking people and that's why i ended
up leaving when i realized they were
full of it
yeah to your point though about you know
uh
i guess we're talking about like
negativity spreading and this mentality
sort of yeah new york radical women
personals and political yeah they'd come
out feeling all angry yeah you take a
bunch of people
who are happy and excited for their job
and you put them in a room
and you're good but one person gets
negative and then
within a week everyone's performance
drop dramatically
and you see do you see what that company
understood
is that the personal is the political so
if you have if you have a company full
of
pissed off people then you're gonna
you're gonna have a bad company if
and if you if you have a country to get
back to that earlier example you have a
country full of heroin addicts
it doesn't matter how wonderfully
written your constitution is
and how beautiful your supreme court
building is if you're if your
nation is full of individuals who are
atrophied and sick and
and disordered you're going to have a
bad country
that's just having an opioid crisis i
mean it's not and that's a literal yeah
right that's a little bit yeah so
uh it's remarkable how easy it is to
spread
anger and negativity and how hard it is
to stop it or spread the positivity what
they call runaway breakdown in science
where one electron and a cloud of plasma
will go and then all
the other ones follow it rapidly and
cause lightning as we know it that's the
formation
and because electrons are such
lightweight they move and they follow
each other very quickly relative to the
proton thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time